and then during the training that's when
they encouraged bunk buddies they wanted
their sexual experience romantic
experience all that stuff to be between
boys but what if you weren't gay yeah
what do you do I don't know man they
probably just kind of girl you have to
like act gay I think you have to pretend
you're gay I don't know so you have to
like lisp all your words and stuff like
that you have to wear a cape and eat hot
dogs very slowly this is Sparta
[Music]
so Vladimir Putin has a very interesting
conspiracy theory I like Putin a lot
yeah what do you like about a uh
um next question not Steve's mine I
can't say why is it physical no no
because like oh he rides horses
no I just thought that it was funny that
uh he was once a KGB member and he
became their president
KGB is like our CIA yeah oh is it is
that funny or is that scary yeah
what a coincidence
so Putin it's a physical
so Putin has an advisor who claims that
the United States is using brainwashing
to make gay Ukrainian super soldiers
yeah because gay soldiers are super yeah
those are superior like we've talked
about here on this very show
the Ukraine's military he believes will
become unified through gay sex just like
the Greek Spartans oh yeah who believes
that Putin does yeah you're gonna have
you're gonna be in the Foxhole with your
brother and that's not your brother
that's your lover as well so why don't
he make a gay super soldier because it's
gay oh oh yeah they don't allow that in
the Russia they don't have gay people in
Russia
as Putin said remember who's leaking
this information
um is he just on Twitter just like
rattling off something how do you find
how do you find these perfect questions
every time that he has no answers this
is Sergey marzov who is Sergey it's
mostly for Joe one of Putin's advisors
you say he's a a military advisor and he
said all this on Russian State TV
he says military theorists and
historians know which army in Greece was
the strongest remember the Spartans they
were unified by a homosexual Brotherhood
I told you guys wait how did they find
that fact by the way how did they know
they found soldiers condoms
[Laughter]
Soldier skeletons they died in that
position and then they were like yeah in
the head and cross they had hands like
this too just in death some guys were
like this
well they found it in the tablets like
the training manual how did they how did
they know that that guy wasn't just
[__] around
the Spartans are big pranksters
hilarious they love that kind of humor
he's like what's the one thing Spartans
are he's like gay oh that'd be funny to
depict
Ed
dude that was like uh it's kind of like
socialism like the way that the Spartans
or the Greeks ran their [__] because the
Spartans were like you're when you're a
child you're the you're you're like a
property of the state you're not a
property of your parents you're like
we're children right like children of
War yeah like well for one you know like
in the movie 300 when they had a
deformed baby they just throw your
[__] ass away like as soon as
you're born they check for defects and
if you're fine they keep you right and
you can at a up until a certain age you
are with your mom
but then immediately
um they take you to like boot camp uh
when you're a certain age as a boy and
then from that fight a wolf it is still
go get you don't fight a wolf but you go
into the Wilderness you can't you have
to sleep in the forest
and then um that's why it's called the
ago gay you got a A goat you gotta hey
go gay oh that's where it comes from oh
that's cool and um they don't feed you
you have to steal food huh really so
they so like you just have to people
know like oh there's gonna be kids
running around town [__] jacking food
and stuff they know that right and on
your graduation you gotta kill a Slave
yeah damn because the uh and the slave
is straight the reason why Spartans are
such a War culture is because they
Enslaved the helots they're like a
neighboring tribe they enslaved their
whole group the difference between them
and the Athenians Athenians would take
on different crews out there tribes and
then they would let them become citizens
so they had a Multicultural Society
whereas Spartans were like we're
Spartans you guys are he Lots or
whatever we got you you guys are slaves
and then they so those people worked
their Farms all that stuff and then um
when they when the kid was ready to like
be of age and graduate they had to go
out into the field for his graduation he
had to find one and kill him wow yeah
poor guy was just farming just farming
and out of nowhere boom yep by a small
child
certain small gay child dude yeah
and during the training that's when they
encouraged bunk buddies they wanted
their sexual experience romantic
experience all that stuff to be between
boys but what if you weren't gay yeah
what happened what do you do I don't
know man they probably just kind of girl
you have to like act gay I think you
have to pretend you're gay I don't know
so you have to like list all your words
and stuff like that you have to wear a
cape yeah and eat hot dogs very slowly
this is Sparta
imagine if there's like a different
language and it's just as gay
but when you watch that 300 movie you're
like oh I've never seen this version
before if you used a certain like
certain amount of syllables when I was
in Middle School you were gay a certain
amount like too many like three plus
using like pretty big words like if you
said like Cornucopia is that gay what
sounds yeah yeah you say I don't know
how the Spartans were able to jab their
Spears with the limp wrist though
like I don't know what okay dudes are
buff dude they are good hygiene and
they're hella fit dude that's where
Circus ladies are gay does it say does
it say anywhere in the manual or
anything that like what the gay
behaviors look like for Spartans did
they was that anything like ours I don't
know what if they were just like if you
the more manly or you were back then
that was considered gay
like the more like brutish you were more
super gay so it makes sense Mark's not
even that brutish dude that's true man
Greeks thought little dicks were hot
really big dicks were like that's like
animal like you're like that's animals
brute animal
small dicks are beautiful I think so too
what was this topic about a neuro
linguistic programming Anthony it's
about it's about it's about Ukrainian
gay soldiers gay super soldiers yeah
because they love each other so much
they're not gonna stop
I mean this is part of by the way this
is just part of like wartime propaganda
you paint your enemy in such a way that
you don't see them as human beings so
that when your soldiers are on the
battlefield they're like they're gay you
can kill them exactly that's what Russia
Russian soldiers and Russians like
through what we've seen like with Putin
saying gays don't exist and [__] and
like I think that they just made gay
such a thing that it's like if the
soldiers are pissed about all this stuff
and they already hate you because you're
Ukrainian [__] now we're dehumanizing
the [__] out of you and then they're
gonna make gay super soldiers but it's
backfiring right because then the
Russians are going into like the front
lines and they're seeing like Ukrainian
soldiers like loving each other and then
they're like just like oh my God it's
love they're overwhelmed with love
they're overwhelmed with they just
[__] flowers and rainbows and like
just Aura and music that's just a
Michael Jackson music video that's sick
though yeah I could see what you're
saying now though with the fact that
like when you have two countries like
this fighting when they they have so
many commonalities you have to find
something that really sets them apart
wedge issue you need something that
wedges people apart right and we do it
all time we did it to the Iraqis right I
feel like it used to be so much easier
to to be racist and hate other countries
back then back then it was easy right
now I don't think it's that easy
I think you could be racist on accident
now well no I think it's easier to be
racist and hate your own country yeah
yeah that's like that's the crazy you
can be racist because you use the wrong
emoji oh that's true yeah what isn't it
harder for armies all over the world to
recruit now and it's also harder for
them to get their soldiers to go out and
kill and stuff I don't know about other
countries but U.S is having a problem
obviously Ukraine's having a problem
they keep on having to open up I think
everyone hates their own country these
days because Russia is having a
recruitment problem and so is China so
it's all a lot of countries a lot of
countries are having recruitment they're
surprises I heard they're they're on an
up and up oh yeah they're they're on the
rise I think Isis got destroyed I think
the Taliban is gonna up and up though
all right that was completely it all
gets renamed it all gets moved and
renewed but yeah no dehumanizing your
enemy is the the name of the game really
and we yeah we did the Iraqis right we
had this little girl come out yeah what
happened with that we had a little girl
come out like in the in for the first
Gulf War and she's testified like under
oath or whatever that Iraqis were taking
babies and put out of incubators and
murdering them and it wasn't true at all
of who's incubators their own oh yeah
yeah so like babies that were born who
were not malnourished or whatever they
were Iraqis were just removing them from
incubators and dropping them on the
ground
and this is all done to weaponize like
fervor in the United States against the
Iraqis that when we went to war people
are like good people are behind it you
know formally behind it yeah so and we
do it all the time now you know we just
we just spent years doing it to every
single country that we've gone to war
with in the history books yeah you just
see that happen every time is the
trigger exactly yeah yeah damn careful
out there with all the propagandas
what's out there good thing we're here
thank you
[Music]